Halle Berry has gotten divorced what
makes the story kind of interesting is
that this divorce has been going on for
something like eight years
Halle Berry has agreed to her child
support payments to her ex-husband they
finalize their divorce eight years after
this custody battle began started in
2015 and here's what Halle Berry said in
2015. it is with a heavy heart that we
have come to the decision to divorce we
move forward with love and respect for
one another and the shared focus of what
is best for our son
that's like saying there's a rising tide
of fat phobia at Cracker Barrel just it
doesn't make any sense that is a
nonsensical statement we are we are
deciding to divorce now because we are
totally focused on what is best for our
child that's not possible
it's not possible